and when you played B5 and Magnus gave
Queen A3 check you are not on the board
for quite some time you are in your uh
in the restroom uh did you calculate
after Queen A7 Bishop takes H3 what was
going through your mind because there
still seemed like black could defend
better
well obviously uh
um like could defend best robots in
general it felt like uh okay uh for
quite some time I was I was regretting
of playing B5 although I think uh after
Bishop H3 okay there is like
capturing on F7 some rookie eight I
believe some rookie check or something
yes so G6
rookie A8 there's Rook G6 so I mean
seven
yeah I mean I take with the queen
because if I take the bishop there's
Rook G6
numbers
rookie 8 King H7
well again like Queen E3 okay Queen if
you check King Jade
[Music]
um
I didn't play at my best after after 100